I loved reading history books growing up
especially those written more like a
storied account of what happened as
opposed to straight facts on the page
there's an implied truth to history when
it's told more so as a story as it
admits that there is no objective truth
to the past history is simply what we
make of it pentiment is written around
this idea providing a means of exploring
a point in history from an outsider's
perspective the protagonist is not
native to the region and we the player
aren't native to the time period rather
than simply retell history pentiment
affords the chance to influence it and
in doing so delves into the subjectivity
of historical record pentiment also
features some fun nods to history with
its fabulous art style and stylish fonts
but the narrative through line of its
three acts a conspiracy of murder
mysteries feels lacking given the
frustrating restrictions to each
investigation and the unceremoniously
abrupt ending
impediment you play as artist Andreas
who is attempting to finish up his
Masterpiece while working for the Abbey
that overlooks the German Town of
tassing a visiting Baron draws the eye
of both the farmers and Crafts People in
town as well as the Christian nuns and
brothers of the Abbey but no one is
prepared when he winds up dead with
Andreas Mentor a man too old and feeble
to have possibly overpowered the baron
penned for the crime the young
illustrator vows to conduct his own
private investigation in hopes of
bringing the true culprit to Justice in
doing so Andreas is drawn into a strange
conspiracy of cryptic notes and unspoken
secrets and his actions shape-tassing in
a story that spans a quarter of a
century your actions have consequences
and pentiment most conversations can
rant in a number of ways depending on
the choices you pick an Andrea's
relationship with those around him is
further shaped by the resulting
consequences often times these
consequences are felt immediately during
the second act of pentiment the game
kept telling me that choice after choice
I was making would be remembered but it
wasn't until the final minutes of the
act that the results of my actions were
revealed and in a twist of fate my
decision to repeatedly be nice to
someone in the hours up to that point
meant that they wouldn't abandon me
during a dangerous situation pentiment
often Delights in the shocking outcomes
in the latter half of its story making
for a far more exciting Act 2 and 3 in
comparison to the rather Meandering
start it certainly doesn't help that the
moment-to-moment gameplay isn't all that
exciting exploration is tediously slow
as fulfilling Quests for folks can see
you having to run from one side of
tassing to the other though pentiment is
depicted in a beautiful artistic style
meant to emulate illuminated manuscripts
and printed books of 16th century Europe
the design of the world only changes
between acts and even then it's not by a
substantial degree talking with
characters to learn more about tassing
and the case you're trying to solve is a
lot of the fun but the game
frustratingly limits how much of that
you can do each day is divided into
sections with Slots of time reserved for
working praying and eating longer
conversations will take up all of your
available time for any one slot meaning
you're unable to meet and talk to every
single person over the course of your
investigation all pentiment entails
however is meeting with and getting to
know the interesting characters or
pursuing leads for the case at hand
that's the extent to which you interact
with pentiment's World putting a limit
on how much of that you can do isn't
inherently bad on its own lots of visual
novels and RPGs utilize something
similar so players are encouraged to
best use their time and get to know the
characters that they like but within the
scope of a mystery too much of a
limitation gets in the way of the fun
you just can't dig enough into the
people of tassing within the confines
allowed leaving a lot of stones unturned
when it's time to present your evidence
a system like this helps differentiate
one playthrough from another other
giving repeat play through some variety
but it can make your first time through
the game feel like you're being
needlessly taxed for wanting to conduct
a detailed examination of every
available suspect I'm also not a fan of
the fact that grabbing dinner with
someone can eat into your limited time
as well punishing you for wanting to
learn more about the town and the
characters unrelated to the case at hand
as it takes place in the early 16th
century pentiment sees you exploring a
Germany that is undergoing a great
religious and social transformation
Martin Luther is becoming a well-known
name in Christian circles and more and
more peasants are being taught to read
for a town like tassing built upon the
ruins of Roman cities and with the
history of druidic paganism this has
resulted in a great variety of people
with different beliefs and morals all
striving to live together in relative
peace pentiment makes this history quite
approachable even if you know very
little about what was going on in
Germany and the rest of Europe in the
1500s at the push of a button the game
will pull back and detail any
significant person place real religion
or event mentioned in the conversation
at hand scribbled out like a student's
notes in the margins of a reference book
It's never enough to bore but just
enough to give you an idea as to why
something or someone is relevant
thankfully the system extends to the
characters who live in tassing as well
even featuring pictures of what they
look like so you can always know who
folks are talking about and you'll want
to know who's who the characters and
their stories are the best part of
pentiment whether it's watching them
grow older and mature over the course of
25 years or witnessing how the
ever-changing perception of religion and
economic class influence the Dynamics of
a town there's a lot of intriguing
history to learn and witness within
pentimate story especially as the game
delves into the events that though
memorable in hindsight don't seem like
anything more than a tragic series of
Misfortune at the moment this is the
core narrative theme of pentiment
playing out over the course of several
decades as andreas's choices influence
the lives of those who inhabit the small
town of tassing and the nearby Abby
regardless of how your investigation in
act 1 plays out Andreas will return two
tasks and years later in Act 2 to find
much has changed even the most flimsy of
reasonings years prior can pass into
gospel over the course of years and the
accusations levied Against The Condemned
will become truth accepted by all most
fully believe that the person accused of
killing the baron actually did it and
the ripples of that assumed truth have
affected the lives of those who are left
some for better and others for worse and
in the same way your choices in Act 2
build into a perceived truth in act
three it's left pentiment as an
intriguing conundrum for me if you ask
me whether I liked the story pinchman
told my answer would be no as you don't
get to see the effects of the concluding
Revelation play out and in a game where
my choices matter in the moment to
moment I want to know how my handling of
the final moment affects the lives of
the few characters I got to know if at
all and yep despite my frustrations with
how narratively unsatisfied find the
ending of pentiment is the game so
clearly captures the essence of what
history ultimately is within that final
moment a collection of tales and
retellings so Twisted together that
there's really no definitive resolution
for anyone and I respect developer
obsidian entertainment's commitment to
remaining true to that more than
anything I love the developers
commitment to stylize fonts throughout
the game pendimit utilizes an assortment
of fonts with messy and curved letters
used for the peasant simpler way of
speaking while something more highly
stylized is used for those within
education there's not as much narrative
complexity to the visual style of
pentiment but it's striking all the same
The Illustrated character models convey
a great deal of detail and further carry
the idea of History resembling a
painting that an artist adds to over and
over with the underlying pentiment the
original image in a painting that
re-emerges when the top layer Fades or
is scrubbed away occasionally shining
through the characters and pentiment are
just pick pictures being painted over
again and again as is pentiment strives
to exist somewhere between a history
book and historical fiction not quite
committing to a detailed look at history
or fulfilling a narrative Arc this is a
detriment to the game's conclusion
dampening my memories of the game save
for the stories of individual characters
witnessing their lives play out as a
narrative Delight only enhanced by the
creative use of pentiment's different
fonts to better convey a person's
societal station or education but
limiting how much time the player
actually has to engage in the game's
best parts hurts the overall experience
too much
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]